euh mes chers collègues je com je
propose de démarrer parce qu' on a déjà
un petit peu de retard et je farais pas
qu'on prenne trop de retard euh
aujourd'hui nous auditionnons donc ell T
and bum et Léo periaapenier qui sont
auteur d'un rapport de liver sur l'armée
allemande dton vender le Bundes vert
face au changement d'air donc moi je
voudrais remercier nos deux invités
d'avoir accepté de venir nous
nous nous rendre compte de leur rapport
parce queon a l'habitude ici à la
Commission en tout cas dans le cadre des
rapports des un et des autres notamment
sur le capacitaire de vous avoir
régulièrement c'est toujours un moment
très agréable parce que évidemment
l'analyse est très fine et et très
intéressante et puis elle est en général
assez cach donc c'est aussi ce que nous
cherchons avoir des gens qui nous disent
les choses telles qu'elles sont donc
merci d'avoir d'avoir accepté de de vous
présenter à nous pour nous parler des
résultats de vos travaux votre audition
constitue évidemment le prolongement
naturel de celle que nous avons eu hier
qui nous a permis d'échanger avec le
chef d'état-majur des armées les défis
que doivent relever nos armées ne sont
pas très différents en effet de ceux que
doit affronter notre voisin allemand
certes nos histoires sont différentes
tout comme nos statutes au regard des
armements stratégiques de notre relation
et de notre relation à l'OTAN mais nous
devons faire face au même défi de la
contestation de l'ordre international de
la montée des périls et du réarmement et
les menaces auxquelles nous sommes
confrontés sont pour les essentielle
commune il est dès lors particulièrement
utile de savoir comment nos voisins
allemands ont abordé le contexte ce
contexte nouveau avec quel diagnostic
avec quel quelles ambitions et quels
moyens avec quels obstacles à franchir
mais également avec quelle vision des
coopérations à mener avec leurs alliés
européens et américains votre rapport
messieur permet de répondre à nombre de
ces questions il est déjà il a déjà
suscité je crois de vives réactions qui
souvent sont concentré sur telle ou
telle proposition mais quand ça réagit
c'est que il y a de l'intérêt et je
crois pourtant que ce rapport a au moins
le mérite important qui est de mettre en
évidence comment a été élaboré dans la
durée à la fois un diagnostic partagé
d'une situation devenue intenable et une
nouvelle doctrine accompagnée de
financement conséquent ce changement
d'air zon vender que vous décrivez ne
saurit en effet se comprendre sans une
augmentation des crédits du budget
annuel pour atteindre 2 % du PIB auquel
est adjoint un fond exceptionnel
zonderer ver Mugen de 100 milliards
d'euros financé par la dette dédiée à
l'acquisition de nouveaux matériels si
votre rapport nous est précieux c'est
aussi qu'il éclaire l'ambition nouvelle
de notre voisin qui vise à établir son
leadership au sein du pôle européen de
l'OTAN à travers le recours au concept
de nation cadre ce concept doit
permettre à la bundesphère d'intégrer
sous son autorité des unités d'autres
nations européennes plus petite il
s'agit bien d'une intégration et non
d'une simple coopération comme vous le
rappelez en expliquant comment les
unités néerlandaises et britannique
entreront de manière native dans la
composition des trois grandes divisions
que prévoit de reconstituer la bundesphè
cette intégration sera d'autant plus
poussée qu'elle s'appuyera sur
l'utilisation de matériel commun issus
de coopération bilatéral mais produit
par l'industrie allemande cette
stratégie interroge bien évidemment la
relation franco-allemande et raisonne
particulièrement dans le contexte des
difficultés que nous rencontrons dans
l'avancement de nos programmes de
défense commun j'observe qu'elle n'est
pas non plus sans poser de question à la
Pologne qui n'entend pas être subordonné
à cette nouvelle bundesv et ce d'autant
moins que la Pologne fait un effort
considérable de monter en puissance
siilon comprend assez bien l'ambition du
zeiton vender il apparaît plus difficile
d'en apprécier la mise en œuvre les
achats sur étagères de matériel
d'origine américaines on ont suscité des
réticences de la part des industriels
allemands ils ont également pour
conséquence et pas que ils ont également
pour conséquence de doter la Bundes ver
d'équipement différents de ceux dont
elle disposait déjà et qu'elle pourrait
acquérir à l'avenir ce qui constitue une
source de coût et de complexité mais ce
qui frappe dans votre rapport ce sont
aussi les interrogations concernant les
les la réalité des moyens mobilisés dans
dans les premières pages de votre
rapport en page 4 vous indiquez en effet
que le fond extraordinaire de 100
milliards vient se rajouter à un budget
régulier ayant lui aussi vocation à
s'accroître pour atteindre à terme la
cible de 2 % du PIB mais plus loin dans
le rapport en page 26 après avoir
indiqué que la forte inflation réduira
nécessairement la portée de ses
financements on en avait parlé au moment
de la préparation de la LPM vous
indiquez que le fond exceptionnel a été
décomposé sur plusieurs années afin de
permettre au budget de la bundesv
d'atteindre 2 % jusqu'en
2027 sachant que rien n'était prévu
au-delà de 2027 ces ces précisions ne
viennent-elles pas contredire ou du
moins nuancer l'ambition initiale de
faire cohabiter un budget régulier
réhaussé et un fond exceptionnel vous
rappelez en outre que le fond de 100
milliards est inférieur de moitié voire
des 2/ers aux besoins qui avaent été
estimé en 2022 vous aurez l'occasion de
nous donner votre sentiment sur ce que
représente réellement les moyens mis au
service du zton vender je saurait achevé
cette présentation sans évoquer l'enjeu
que représente la stratégie allemande
pour notre pays et le regard que que
vous portez sur les débats et les choix
qui ont émaillé la récente loi de
programmation militaire Vous invitez
dans votre rapport les responsables de
notre pays parmi lesquels figure bien
sûr les parlementaires à je cite prendre
en compte l'évolution de la place que se
donne l'Allemagne dans sa propre
stratégie de défense et d'inluence sans
appeler pour autant et je vous cite à
nouveau un changement d'ire à la
française j'ai pourtant envie de vous
interroger sur ce point notre stratégie
de défense ne manque-t-elle pas encore
d'un concept global pour repenser notre
rôle en Europe et dans le monde notre
pays ne doit-il pas également envis la
la reconstitution de grandes unités en
intégrant des capacités d'autres nations
européennes comme le fait l'Allemagne
c'est d'ailleurs la voie ouverte par la
coopération avec la Belgique le fameux
partenariat camo la création d'un fond
exceptionnel ne ser ne serait-elle pas
également pertinente pour corriger les
insuffisances de la LPM qui n'a pas pu
prendre l'exacte mesure des besoins dans
un contexte qui a déjà beaucoup évolué
en quelques mois les questions soulevées
par votre rapport sont nombreuse et
passionnante je vais donc vous céder la
parole après jeerai évidemment la parole
comme il se fait de tradition à
l'ensemble des collègues qui souhaitent
vous interroger et je rappelle que cette
audition est captée et diffusée sur le
site internet du Sénat je vous laisse la
parole dans dans l'ordre que vous
souhaitez et pour nous présenter les
choses et puis ensuite on passera un jeu
de questions-réponses des collègues
présents merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup monsieur le
sénateur Mesdames et Messieurs les les
sénateurs pour pour
ces pour cette invitation tout d'abord
vous l'avez signalé vous avez à
plusieurs reprise au cours de cette
année 2023 et par le passé fait appel au
aux auditions des chercheurs de
l'ffer nous répondons toujours présent
c'est une des missions fondamentales tel
que nous le concevons dans notre dans
notre fonction d'intérêt général et
d'éclairer la décision et le débat
public que de pouvoir contribuer aussi
utilement que possible et que vous le
jugerez au travau du législateur et
et et aux travaux parlementaires don
nous sommes nous-mêmes par ailleurs de
grands consommateurs et donc de ce point
de vue-l je pense que l'écosystème est
est pleinement
respecté pour aller tout de suite sur
sur les les les points
essentiels liés à à cette étude je pense
que il est important de de signaler tout
d'abord
que même si le document a été publié
traduit en en français et en et en
anglais c'est bien public français qui
était visé initialement pour finalement
changer un petit peu le regard qui est
habituellement porté en France sur les
la politique de défense allemande avec
des attentes qui après réflexion nous
ont semblé être décalé par rapport à la
manière
dont le la République fédérale elle-même
et la Bundes ver envisager sa
transformation son ambition et ses défis
en propos limininaire je me contenterai
de signaler quatre grands points quatre
quatre grandes euh on va dire leçon que
nous que nous retirons de cette étude et
puis je laisserai
Léo compléter sur sur sur d'autres
aspect notamment peut-être sur sur sur
les défis le plus capacitair mais on va
essayer d'assz assez vite laisser la
place au aux questions le premier point
euh et je pense que c'est important
c'est que le tiit and vender la tiit and
vender le changement d'air qu'on
pourrait traduire en français qui a été
annoncé par le chancelier schz dans son
discours du 27 février 2022 au lendemain
du choc de
l'agression russe contre contre
l'Ukraine cette ce ce changement est bel
et bien en marche euh il y a eu il a
existé des des un certain nombre de de
réflexes dubitatif ou scepti du côté du
côté français après les annonces face au
au manque de rapidité dans dans dans sa
mise en œuvre notamment au cours de
l'année
2022 avec un ministère de la Défense
allemand qui semblait manquer de
leadership politique euh pour
autant les choses ont changé début 2023
et on voit bien que le la mémoire du du
choc du du 24 février demeure demeure
présente et oui l'Allemagne est en train
de
transformer son rapport aux questions de
défense elle le fait en fait depuis plus
longtemps que ça mais aujourd'hui elle
AG gravi une nouvelle marche et les
choses les les les choses sont sont Bell
et bien en marche pour autant évidemment
il ne faut pas négliger les défis
considérables
qui se pose à cette transformation ces
défis sont au moins de qu ordre d'abord
un ordre capacitaire avec effectivement
une
situation en terme d'équipement de
l'armée de la bounus vert qui qui était
qui part de très loin qui souffre
d'années de vache maigre si on compare à
la situation française on voit un petit
peu près à peu près tous les
euh tous les afres dont nous avons
souffert mais qui en ce qui les concerne
étit bien bien au-delà en terme de
disponibilité technique de matériel en
terme de de fonction de
soutien en terme de d'unités qui ont été
creusées à l'intérieur de leur de leur
dotation l'armée l'armée allemande vient
de très loin et donc le défi capacitaire
est considérable le deuxième défi et euh
humain en terme de personnel euh voici
des années que euh l'armée les armées
allemand ne parviennent pas à honorer
leur cible en terme
d'objectif une cible à 203000 hommes
pour l'ensemble des des des des forces
armées allemandes a été fixé il y a
plusieurs années ils sont aujourd'hui à
plus de 20000 euh euh post non pourvu
euh donc qui qui atteste à la fois de
temp
démographique qu'on connaît sur le dans
dans la dans la société allemande mais
aussi de manque d'attractivité du
métiers des armes et ce en dépit du fait
de de soldes qui sont structurellement
supérieure à celle qu'on peut
trouver dans d'autres pays notamment en
France on a des éléments chiffrés qui
sont dans le document Le troème défi
vous l'avez avz évoqué monsieur le
Président est d'ordre capacitaire euh et
d'ordre budgétaire pardon sur sur le
plan le sur le plan budgétaire le
l'effet de rattrapage sur la la cible
des 2 % est effectivement
euh considérable le le le fond
exceptionnel ZF Mogan va leur permettre
sans doute sur l'année 2024 et peut-être
2025 d'atteindre les 2 % ce qui
permettra
à l'Allemagne de faire bonne figure si
je puis dire au sommet de Washington en
juillet 2024 avec cette cible mais ce
fond exceptionnel sera
tari à partir de
2026 et aura été donc essentiellement
consommé pour l'acquisition de matériel
extrêmement onéreux dont le l'avion
multifonction
F35 et et et donc vous aurez un effet de
trou d'air et donc c'est seulement au
prix d'un effort
considérable de d'augmentation du budget
régulier de la défense que ces trous
capacitaires et également humains
pourront être pouront être comblés ça
implique pour l'Allemagne évidemment et
c'est mon dernier 4e 4e grand défi des
une transformation de la mentalité
politique aujourd'hui d'ors et déjà le
budget fédéral de la défense dépasse
euh le plus plusieurs grands budgets euh
de sur des des des enjeux sociaux et
économiques euh combiné euh donc c'est
la question euh en anglais on parle de
welfare versus warfare state est-ce que
l'État-providence allemand tel qu'il
s'est constitué dans une dimension
fédérale évidemment doit en partie euh
sacrifier euh ses ses ses dépenses
sociales et économiques sur l'hôtel de
la sécurité de la défense et donc ce ce
ce ce débat politique aujourd'hui n'est
pas tranché en Allemagne et et va sans
doute se poser avec davantage d'acuité
dans les années à venir qu'il ne se pose
aujourd'hui encore une fois à l'ône du
tarissement programmé si je peux dire du
Zander fermugan de ce de ce fond spécial
donc c'est ce c'est mon premier point le
la tion V est en marche les choses
changent mais quatre grand défis qui qui
qui qui se font mon deuxème point
c'est de dire que l'armée allemande même
si elle va devenir
extrêmement même si cette transformation
est est en cours ne va pas se
transformer du jour au lendemain ni même
à terme en une armée d'emploi au sens où
nous l'entendons en France et là c'est
je pense le le grand biais que nous
avons de ce côté-ci si Duin lorsqu'on
regarde la Bundes ver c'est que on se
demande
si l'Allemagne est enfin sérieux sur les
questions de défense on s'attend à avoir
quelque chose qui ressemble à une armée
française de l'autre côté du RIN ça ne
sera pas le cas une armée tourner vers
les opérations extérieures tourner vers
les
missions de de gestion de crise ce n'est
pas ce en quoi la buoundes ver a
l'intention de se transformer so en quoi
euh
la République fédérale ainttention de
transformer ce ces ces forces armées ce
sera une armée tournée résolument vers
la défense continentale défense du
continent européen dans une logique
j'insiste bien de dissuasion
conventionnelle terme qui est évidemment
aujourd'hui onis dans la culture
stratégique française du fait de notre
héritage et de notre de notre tradition
de dissuasion nucléaire mais qui
correspond pour l'Allemagne évidment
évidemment à ses capacités en tant
qu'État non doté mais aussi dans une
certaine mesure au concept stratégique
de l'OTAN
de défense et dissuasion de l'espace
euroatlantique pour en parler si vous
voulez du rapport allemand à la au au
facteur nucléaire il a lui aussi évolué
mais fondamentalement la bundesver se
projette aujourd'hui comme une armée de
dissuasion conventionnelle c'est-à-dire
une armée qui n'a pas vocation tant à
faire la guerre qu'être crédible pour
pouvoir dissuader un adversaire de d'une
agression dans l'espace euroatlantique
et notamment sur le flan est de
l'alliance avec évidemment le le la la
situation en Russie en Ukraine mais
aussi sur les États baltes et le long de
la frontière biélorusse qui est
aujourd'hui en en état donc c'tait mon
deuxième point euh ça ne devient pas une
armée ça ne deviendra pas une armée
d'emploi au sens où nous l'entendons en
France mais une armée de défense
continentale tourné vers la disuion
conventionnelle le troisième point
j'accélère est euh lié au fait que dans
cette logique de défense continentale et
de dissuasion conventionnelle la bounuse
vert se perçoit très fondamentalement
comme euh l'un des piliers sinon le
pilier principal de l'Alliance
atlantique faut revenir sur l'ADN la
création même de la Bundes ver comme
l'armée de l'OTAN en 1955 après l'échec
de la Communauté
européenne de défense c'est un pour la
bounus verre un retour au fondamentaux à
bien des égards à l'armée de la guerre
froide avec comme grande différence que
au contraire de la guerre froide
l'Allemagne ne sera plus le champ de
bataille de de la conflictualité future
mais la rotule logistique l'arrière
essentielle avec avec une ligne de front
qui se déplace désormais plusieurs
centaines 2 km vers l'Est où l'armée
allemande entend désormais occuper une
position essentielle avec une
transformation qui a été euh adopté dès
2014 au sommet du pays de gale de
l'Alliance atlantique transformation qui
a été euh mal perçu mal identifié en
France car comme c'est souvent le cas en
Allemagne euh mené sans fanfaronade
excessive celle de la du concept de
nation cadre qui a été adopté par par
par l'Alliance à cette époque une époque
où je précise le la France était tout à
ses opérations extérieures au Sahel et
au Moyen-Orient où le Royaume-Uni était
en train de se remettre de ses 10 ans de
contribution à la guerre américaine
contre le terrorisme et euh dans les
afres bientôt du brexit l'Allemagne
s'est estimé être l'acteur principal en
Europe crédible pour constituer euh
une des des coalition ad hoc à travers
ce ce ce concept de nation 4adre qui a
deux finalement
sous s sous dééveloppement un
opérationnel et un capacitaire et
industriel sur le plan opérationnel ce
concept de nation cadre pousse depuis
2014 et de manière accélérée depuis 2022
l'Allemagne a constitué une architecture
de commandement et de contrôle intégré
sous
euh sous son sa sa sa supervision ou son
en cadrement avec effectivement vous
l'avez dit un certain nombre de pays les
Pays-Bas en tête d'autres d'autres
également comme comme la Lituanie par
exemple dans une moindre mesure la
Roumanie la République tchèque à
s'intégrer aujourd'hui dans des
structures de commandement intégrées en
Allemagne essentiellement opéré par les
Allemands les Pays-Bas sont
effectivement les plus avancés là-dessus
notamment dans le domaine terrestre avec
le modèle
divisionnaire allemand qui intègrre
désormais les trois
brigades des forces terrestres
néerlandaises vous avez d'autres
structures de commandement similaire
dans le champ maritime avec le le le
commandement de pour la pour la mer
Baltique mise en place par l'Allemagne
et puis dans le champ aérien dans le
domaine aérien avec la constitution d'un
d'un groupe aérien multinational qui a
vocation à former le le rôle de gfac euh
donc de de de de commandement la
composante aérienne pour une opération
interarmée interalliée la dimension
capacitaire enfin euh du de de ce
concept de nation cadre avec une
industrie de défense allemande qui à la
fois intégrée et intégratrice avec un
rôle essentiel euh des États-Unis euh
j'ai j'ai j'ai pas cité pour l'instant
mais évidemment la la la relation
germano-américaine est essentielle euh
de de ce point de vue-là aussi bien sur
le plan industriel que sur le plan
opérationnel avec une industrie
aéronautique qui aujourd'hui est très
intégré et le choix du F35 de ce point
de vue-là n'est n'est pas une surprise
et apparaît même comme comme logique euh
de de de notre point de vue et une
industrie allemande elle-même qui se
veut intégratrice de capacités
européennne mais les Léo on dira
peut-être un mot avec notamment dans le
champ terrestre et euh également
naval de grands contrats et une
clientèle européenne élevée euh mon 4e
et et et dernier point porte sur les
limites de cette ambition allemande et
je pense que il faut les regarder euh
l'Allemagne se perçoit désormais
effectivement comme intégratrice de
petites nations cela marche notamment
voilà avec avec les Pays-Bas avec avec
un certain nombre de pays baltes avec
avec des pays d'urope Europe centrale
orientale mais il y a un défi quand même
sur l'intégration de de pays avec des
des forces armées considérables à
forcerie des pays deté on voit bien
aujourd'hui les difficultés que cette
posture allemande
intégratrice pose vis-à-vis de la France
puisque le réflex binational
franco-allemand n'existe plus de l'autre
côté du rein encore une fois depuis 2014
l'Allemagne se perçoit comme
intégratrice euh elle-même à l'échelle
européenne et donc pas dans une logique
de moteur
euh bilatéral que que que nous
continuons à à à voir en France
euh c'est euh donc donc ça pose un
problème avec l'Allemagne avec la France
mais on le voit bien effectivement du
côté du côté polonais le défi est est
également considérable même si on peut
espérer que les choses et la relation se
détendent aujourd'hui avec un avec
peut-être une une coalition en Pologne
euh qui sera sans doute moins euh euh
moins orienté sur le sur le sur le sur
sur les tensions politiques euh avec
l'Allemagne une relation euh avec le
Royaume-Uni qui qui qui peine encore à
se dégager entre l'Allemagne et le
Royaume-Uni euh et puis une relation
germano-italienne euh qui euh qui existe
qui est qui est qui est forte mais qui
qui aujourd'hui euh n'est pas non plus
en mesure de de d'offrir toute la
dimension intégratrice euh du du FNC
allemand voilà je je je m'arrêterai là
sur ces sur ces propos liminires euh
donc quatre quatre points le Titan V est
est bel et bien en marche l'Allemagne ne
va pas devenir une armée d'emploi la
bundesver ne va pas devenir une armée
d'emploi au sens où nous l'entendons en
France en France mais de défense
conventionnelle euh euh et continentale
en Europe la Bundes ver pour se faire se
veut moins comme une armée nationale que
comme une armée intégratrice
probablement une forme de pilier
européen de l'OTAN et il existe enfin
des limites à cette ambition je vous
remercie pour votre attention je cède la
la parole rapidement à à Léo qui qui
complètera m merci beaucoup je vais
aller assez vite pour laisser le plus de
place possible aux questions simplement
quelques points qui me semblent
important peut-être à retenir ou même à
développer de ces mois de recherche
étudier l'Allemagne et la situation
allemande la politique de défense
allemande ça a aussi étéétud et
nous-même au sens où c'était questionner
la place de la France dans l'OTAN dans
l'Europe dans notre rapport à ce que
c'est que la culture stratégique
Atlantique et la position de la France
par rapport à tout ce qui a été
peut-être les héritages de la guerre
froide mais la position face à la Russie
et un autre point qui a été saillant
c'est que la France considère encore en
Europe l'Allemagne comme son premier
partenaire militaire et de défense il
s'avère que la réciproque n'est pas vrai
la France n'est plus le premier
partenaire militaire de l'Allemagne en
Europe c'est et de très loin au niveau
de l'intégration même si politiquement
ils ne le déclareront pas comme ça ça
reste les Pays-Bas vienent ensuite
évidemment la les États-Unis et d'autres
pays d'Europe mais pour le moment dans
l'état des coopérations
franco-allemandes que ce soit de manière
industrielle ou militaire la France
n'est clairement pas le premier
partenaire militaire de
l'Allemagne de même que la France a très
longtemps parlé de défense européenne
d'armée européenne de souveraineté
européenne au vu des dynamiques
actuelles l'armée européenne c'est
l'armée allemande c'est la solution
qu'elle propose à ses partenaires
européens en fait le socle d'une future
armée européenne très différente de ce
que la France pouvait envisager comme
armée européenne mais les faits sont là
euh et enfin qui est un élément qui est
très qui revient très souvent quand on
parle de franco-allemand notamment avec
des militaire français c'est nous nous
avons du mal à travailler avec les
Allemands parce que Français et
Allemands n'ont pas la même culture
stratégique et la question qui a qui a
qui est issue de ces m mois de recherche
c'est d'accord qui a le même culture
stratégique que la France en dehors
peut-être de l'Angleterre qui enfin du
Royaume-Uni qui n'est aujourd'hui plus
dans l'Europe et qui en Europe
continentale au sein de l'Union
européenne a la même culture stratégique
que la France pas grand monde ce travail
là va être complété par assez vite par
un travail sur la relation
franco-italienne pour essayer de
poursuivre et voir si on peut trouver
des similitudes aux évolutions de la
relation franco-allemande et comprendre
aussi peut-être ce que comment la France
a géré ces ces partenariats européens
pour voir si on peut trouver des points
communs mais globalement dans cette
espèce de compétition pour le leadership
régional qui qui s'estétablit à demi-mot
entre ce que la France a voulu proposer
comme modèle de de sou européenne est ce
que l'Allemagne propose la question de
cette culture stratégique va être
décisive puisque en l'état la culture
stratégique allemande qui est beaucoup
plus intégré à l'OTAN qui est beaucoup
plus basé sur une approche continentale
des problématiques de défense reste pour
je pense beaucoup de nos partenaires
européens plus attractive que ce que la
France a pu proposer et propose
aujourd'hui alors que les OPEC sont en
voie d'extinction et ce qui pouvit être
ce qui a été la base d'une tentative
d'intégration notamment avec la force
àuba et ce qui tout ce qui s'est passé
au Mali en l'état un des moyens pour la
France de se différencier de l'Allemagne
par rapport aux craintes peut-être que
les partenaires européens peuvent avoir
ce sera de proposer une offre avec un
plus attractive qui sera moins centré
sur l'OTAN certes mais qui permettra
peut-être qui offrira peut-être un
partage plus équitable des tâches qui
est aujourd'hui une des craintes
notamment dans les pays baltes euh je
pense qu'on peut passer plus rapidement
aux question vu que mon collègue a dit
la totalité de ce qui était important
merci beaucoup pour ces quelques
éléments de de réponse ou en tout cas de
traduction de ce qui a été mis dans le
rapport j'ai deux demandes de parole et
après j'aurai quelques questions
personnelles sans doute je je n'en
manque pas je laisse la parole à hlè
conour s'il y a d'autres personnes qui
veulent prendre la parole n'hésitez pas
à nous le faire savoir pour qu'on vous
puisse vous indiquer allez Hélène pardon
vas-y je t'en prie tuas vu j'ai commencé
par toi aujourd'ui oui merci quelle
élégance merci monsieur le Président oui
deux points merci d'abord pour pour
votre exposé votre excellent rapport
également un point technique et un point
plutôt politique le point technique je
voudrais revenir sur le mgcs euh dans
votre rapport vous dites assez justement
que bon les perspectives d'avenir de de
ce projet emblématique ne sont pas
aujourd'hui évidentes mais que une
commande de
BT allégerait la pression sur le sur les
Lecler restants en attendant 2040 et
donc l'arrivée de cet hypothétique
nouveau char euh attendu donc est-ce que
vous pouvez nous en dire un petit peu
plus sur le sujet et le deuxième point
est un point un peu plus politique
aujourd'hui l'Allemagne fait face à des
difficultés économiques on va dire suite
à un certain nombre de choix qu'elle a
fait par le passé choix énergétique
dépendance vis-à-vis de de certains pays
notamment la Russie aussi les choix
économiques d'une dépendance économique
vis-à-vis de de la Chine or
l'Allemagne repose et a fait ce choix-là
euh sur la la la sécurité utanienne donc
des États-Unis et si demain les tensions
sinino-américaines s'exacerbaient et que
les Américains demandent à l'Allemagne
de faire un choix entre leur sécurité ou
leur économie
euh quel choix ferait-elle
pensez-vous je me permets juste de
traduire quand même pour nos collègues
nouvellement arrivés à la Commission le
EBT euh le embbt c'est en fait le char
intermédiaire entre ce qui pourrait être
aujourd'hui Lecler et le futur char du
futur mgcs c'est un char en quelque
sorte avec le corps du léopard et la et
la tête du du du d'un d'un char qui
pourrait être fait par un exter donc en
fait c'est un espèce de vous expliquerez
peut-être mieux que moi mais de de
situation intermédiaire entre mgcs et
Lecler ou léopard
merci beaucoup euh pour le MBT pour le
mgcs d'abord le mgcs comme le SCAF comme
divers autres projets qui ont été lancés
à la fin des années 2010 sont des
projets qui sont d'abord politiques et
qui rencontrent un problème majeur qui
est que si la partie politique a une
volonté qui qui est indispensable la
partie industrielle et militaire elle
reste défaillante sur ces questions là
pour le mgcs en particulier donc pour le
projet de char du futur l'idée a été de
créer
un pas un consortium mais une nouvelle
entité qui regrouperait Nexter donc le
producteur de de blindé français et KMV
le plus petit des deux grands
producteurs de blindé allemands pour qui
ont des compétences complémentaires
sachant que Nexter est en mesure de
faire l'armement kV en mesure de faire
la motorisation et la caisse pour
produire à l'avenir un char du futur à
l'horizon
2040 assez rapidement sachant que
l'Allemagne était dans en position de
leader sur ce projet là où la France
était sur le SCAR C Ry metal qui est
l'autre grand producteur et un
concurrent acharné à la fois de Nexter
et de KMV a été rajouté au projet et est
venu s'ajouter donc au consortium knnds
qui regroupait les deux les deux
premiers
acteurs le problème comme je disais
c'est que si la volonté politique est là
la volonté industrielle reste très
défaillante au sens où vous faites
travailler ensemble des gens qui soit
sont des concurrents soit sont très
clairement en situation
d'inimitié et que voilà la volonté
militaire est encore plus compxe puisque
les Français et les Allemands n'ont pas
forcément les mêmes désirs pour leur
char de combat un des moyens et encore
une fois c'est une piste de résoudre ce
souci de d'absence de de synergie
industrielle serait de faire en sorte
que knnds ne soit pas une coquille vide
puisque à l'heure actuelle ce n'est que
ça c'est une coquille c'est une forme
puisqu'il n'a aucun produit en commun en
dehors de le MBT qui est avant tout un
démonstrateur ça n'a pas vocation à être
un produit industrialisable pour le
moment ça reste un un échelan un jalon
sur le chemin du mgcs néanmoins le
projet va mal je pense que on peut le
dire aujourd'hui parce que les Allemands
l'industrie allemande considère d'avoir
pas besoin de la France pour produire un
char au regard de ses succès techniques
et commerciaux dans ce domainelà c'est
pourquoi l'idée certes un peu peut-être
osée au regarde de certains retours
qu'on a eu dessus
de d'armer une unité commune
franco-allemande sur sur
BT en attendant le le mgcs vient
résoudre plusieurs plusieurs problèmes à
savoir donner l'occasion à knnds
d'exister industriellement à travers un
produit commun sans forcément besoin
d'en produire d'en acheter une des
quantités a rente mais simplement les
discussions qu'on a eu depuis la
publication nous ont permis d'aller plus
loin au sens où on peut même envisager
quelque chose d'encore un peu plus
audacieux pourquoi ne pas transformer la
Brigade franco-allemande en une brigade
blindée sur BT puisque on le voit
notamment pour le cas de l'Armée de
l'Air le la la l'escadrie qui est basée
à Evreux l'escadriie de trans SP qui est
franco-allemande qui est basée sur un
matériel commun est une des rares
initiatives qui à l'heure actuelle
fonctionne on peut envisager dans l'idée
de répéter l'expérience pour l'armée de
terre tout en renforçant la la
proposition en rétablissant au moins
partiellement la colollocqualisation des
unités de la Brigade franco-allemande
qui depuis sa disparition n'a fait que
se déliter puisque les gens qui
sontartenur à cette même brigade ne se
connaissent plus ce qui est un énorme
problème donc l'idée était formons au
moins une unité avec un matériel commun
la France achètera pas de léopard 2 le
Lecler n'est plus produit le MBT a
l'avantage d'exister et de pouvoir être
redévelopper pour devenir
industrialisable à moyen terme et
permettra à la France de durer à mon
sens dans le temps sur le blindé lourd
sachant que en l'état et vu le retard
déjà pris par le mgcs si même il advient
sous sa forme telle
qu'envisagé il va être difficile de
faire tenir le parc de Lecler jusqu'à
sachant absolument
que l'une des conclusions du rapport
c'est aussi qu'il faut être réaliste sur
le paysage industriel et économique
français comme allemand et que euh quoi
qu'il arrive on voilà on ne fera pas
disparaître le poids de r métal qui
évidemment devra trouver une place dans
les grands projets de défense au moins
du côté du côté allemand et sans doute
et et sans doute européen et et l'une
des manières aussi de s'en
sortir au-delà d'essayer de faire
rentrer au
chasepied dans une voiture de place une
une troisième qui qui qui qui est plus
grande que que que les deux autres
réunies
euh de considérer le mgcs pour ce qui
doit être c'est-à-dire non pas seulement
uniquement comme un char comme un char
d'assaut mais aussi comme un
système de système et et dans lequel il
y a évidemment il devrait y avoir en
tout cas d'autres d'autres composantes
c'est aujourd'hui en tout cas ce qui
permet au SCAF de d'être
davantage d'être moins sur la c que que
que mgcs même si encore une fois compte
tenu des besoins industriels des uns et
des autres ça ça ça reste difficile et
simplement effectivement un tout petit
complément le gros avantage de le MBT en
l'état c'est qu'il ne réunit que KMV et
kmds nextter r Méal est en dehors donc
ça l'avantage de ça sera pas forcément
le mgcs mais ça permettra au moins
d'arriver une synergie potable sachant
que R métal est aujourd'hui le gros
élément bloquant dans le
programme merci pour votre question
madame la sénatrice sur sur la question
du du du choix économique versus choix
sécuritaire évidemment c'est c'est
essentiel et c'est et et et c'est très
présent à à l'esprit de la réflexion
stratégique en Allemagne emagne euh
évidemment euh la la dépendance
économique à l'export euh visàis du
marché chinois mais aussi sur la chaîne
euh d'approvisionnement euh avec avec
une partie de de la de la chaîne de
valeur de l'industrie allemande
industrie civile qui est aujourd'hui euh
présente en Chine est est un sujet euh
majeur la question du découplage euh
pour l'instant est refusé au profit
d'une notion de dérisquage euh de de de
ces chaînes de valeur euh le dérisquage
en France est perçu quand même avant
tout comme une une forme de réduction de
la de la dépendance à la euh à
l'économie chinoise en Allemagne tel que
on le conçoit ça se traduit surtout euh
et de manière des fois un peu paradoxale
par un réinvestissement euh en Chine de
manière à ce que les
filiales présentes en République
populaire de Chine de de l'Allemagne
puissent être relativement autonome le
si d'aventure
euh une une forme de rupture devait
adevenenir donc donc évidemment ça ça
peut paraître extrêmement étrange sinon
désorientant de d'entendre des grands
groupes de
l'automobile du du secteur industriel de
l' mobile allemand annoncé régulièrement
des investissements à coup de milliards
euh dans
euh en en Chine alors même que le
message envoyé du côté du côté américain
est est est est est divergent donc
aujourd'hui la l'économie allemande et
si je puis dire l'ensemble de la société
allemande n'est pas prête euh à assumer
ce choix pour autant
euh il me semble clair que si euh
d'aventure il devait être confronté à à
à ce dilemme euh c'est le choix
sécuritaire et le choix américain euh
qui sera qui qui l'emportera euh
qu'ilemportera si véritablement ils sont
confrontés à ce murlà euh après je pense
qu'ils feront tout pour pouvoir
maintenir autant que possible
euhh les relations ou en tout cas
prendre le plus de temps possible pour
évoluer
euh on va dire de manière graduelle et
non pas de manière brutale
euh sur sur leur leur propre leur propre
balance économique et leur propre leur
propre système économique évidemment
voilà c'est en tout cas le le le message
du côté américain est très fortement
entendu ils ont été à plusieurs reprises
à l'époque de l'administration de Donald
Trump déjà sommé de faire des choix
cornéliens auquel ils sont pas parvenus
et qui ont d'une certaine manière aussi
renforcer de manière très temporaire
l'idée d' autonomie stratégique
européenne en Allemagne aujourd'hui ça
ça ça s'est à nouveau effacé face voilà
au au au visage on va dire plus jovial
de l'administration Biden les choses
pourraient pourraient évidemment évoluer
tout dépend de la manière dont dont la
pression américaine se se traduira et et
la brutalité avec lequelle elle pourrait
s'exercer mais mais fondamentalement
dans l'héritage et les choix euh les
choix politiques politiqu Allemands le
la seule chose sur laquelle il sera
impossible de transiger c'est c'est
cette cette garantie transatlantique de
sécurité merci beaucoup la parole est à
Olivier
sigolotti merci monsieur le Président
messieurs merci pour votre rapport et et
votre présentation avec ma collègue
Michel greum nous sommes rapporteur du
programme 118 préparation et emploi des
forces et à ce titre nous sommes
particulièrement attentifs
et sensible aux éléments constitutifs de
la DT et de la DTO or votre rapport met
en exerg un certainement un certain
nombre d'éléments assez alarmants en
matière de de disponibilité technique de
de la
bundosph alors certes comparaison n'est
pas raison mais 3 à 400 m sur 15 étit
disponible en 2017 13 NH 90/
58 105 léopard 2 sur 224 et et 12 tigres
sur 62 alors certes cette situation éta
celle de 2017 mais vous pointez
également que la situation reste très
préoccupante aujourd'hui
euh un certain nombre de systèmes
d'armes anciens ont une DTO inférieure à
50 % et votre rapport précise que
lorsque la bndesver a pris pour la
première fois la responsabilité de la
force de réaction rapide de l'OTAN les
unités désignées avaient été contraintes
de se livrer une cannibalisation du
reste de l'armée pour obtenir un certain
nombre de pièces
détachées la question que je me pose
aujourd'hui et que je vous pose
messieurs comment peut-on parler de
pilier européen de l'OTAN avec une telle
DTO euh est-ce que l'on peut considérer
la Bundes ver comme une armée alliée
vous avez rappelé que la Bundes ver
n'était pas une armée d'emploi qu'elle
n'avait pas vocation à le devenir euh
comment est-ce que l'on peut aujourd'hui
parler d'un pilier européen de l'OTAN
avec une telle disponibilité alors
certes le gouvernement allemand et ce
n'est pas sans nous rappeler quelques
éléments franco-français a décidé de de
classifier les éléments de de la DT il
me semble que c'est un sujet que nous
avons abordé très largement au sein de
de notre commission euh mais comment
est-ce que l'on peut euh avoir des
éléments plus récents sur la
disponibilité technique ou la
disponibilité technique opérationnelle
des des différents éléments de de la
BNDES ver et ma question est-ce que l'on
peut réellement penser que la BNDES ver
est encore aujourd'hui un pilier
européen de de l'OTAN je reviens
simplement sur le léopard 2 puisqu'on en
a parlé dans le casadre du conflit
russo-ukrainien 105 matériels
disponibles sur 200 24 nous nous
plaignions parfois du manque de
disponibilité de nos charlescler je
pense que il y a matière à s'interroger
merci je je vais je me permets parce que
j'avais tout à l'heure très peu de
demandes de questions j'en ai un peu
plus maintenant donc je propose d'en
faire deux et puis par série de de s
plus facile donc je laisse la parole à
Roger
carucci je je seraai très rapide
monsieur le Président euh l'Allemagne a
acheté le système du DOM de fer
israélien euh elle a demandé visiblement
à plusieurs États européens de s'y
associer pour des raisons diverses la
France ne s'y associe pas qu'est-ce que
vous pensez de la position allemande de
l'acquisition de ce d de fer et question
subsidiaire si je puis dire
sous-amendement Israël se dote pour
compléter le système du D de fer d'un
système de destruction
par laser qui est mise en place ces
jour-ci j'ai cru comprendre que
l'Allemagne évidemment très intéressé
voulait des avenants à son contrat sur
le D de fer pour avoir le système laser
en plus est-ce que vous en savez plus
là-dessus je vous en
prie alors sur la
DTO alors comme on l'a souligné dans
dans le papier les chiffres c'est
chiffre là date effectivement 2017
sachant que nous sommes 3 ans après que
les budgets militair allemands ai tout
juste commencé àéaugmenté après un un
plancher historique quasiment en dessous
des 1 %. donc la DTO pour le enfin je
pense qu'en France aussi on sait que
c'est complexe et long à faire augmenter
donc je pense que nous étions dans cette
situation là dans la queue de trainune
situation qui était probablement encore
pire 3 ans avant mais qui était en voie
d'amélioration et ça pour le coup tous
nos interlocuteurs qu'il soit chercheurs
industriel militaire nous ont confirmé
que quand bien même les chiffres étaient
passés en off s'ils ne sont pas
excellent au sens où ils sont
comparables au chiffres américains il
reste bien meilleur et en voie
d'amélioration je il est évidemment très
difficile d'avoir des des chiffres
précis nos camarades F tanker d'outrerin
nous ont quand même donné quelques
éléments en nous expliquant que sur bien
des plans ça allait mieux euh néanmoins
j'attirai aussi votre attention comme je
disais dans dans ma courte présentation
euh observer l'Allemagne s'observa
nous-même et il s'avère que une partie
des chiffres de disponibilité présenté
dans par par l'Allemagne était assez
souvent très proche des chiffres
français et le constat que les matériels
très modernes et les matériels très
anciens avaient souvent des taux
disponibilité similaire je pense que
notamment on a tous vu les chiffres de
disponibilité des hélicoptères
français je j'ose croire que ça s'
amélioré depuis grâce à la
verticalisation des contrats de de
maintenance mais on était aussi très
très proche voire pire dans certains cas
de de ces chiffresl
voilà l'Allemagne enfin quelques points
là-dessus la bounus ver a évidemment eu
conscience du du problème alors bon
effectivement c'est très difficile de
rentrer dans ces chiffres notamment
autour de de la question de l'assiette
et du périmètre à partir de de quel
nombre
euh de de plateformes est calculé la la
disponibilité technique et la
disponibilité technique opérationnelle
qui sont pas qui sont pas les mêmes
choses et donc les chiffres annoncés ou
ceux qui F dans la presse doivent être
mis en contexte avec avec des éléments
qui sont souvent absents globalement en
tout cas une les les enjeux de la
maintenance et de la disponibilité ont
bien été pris en compte euh du côté de
la Deutsche marine par exemple donc la
la la marine allemande il y a des choses
intéressantes qui ont été faites sur la
renationalisation de chantier naval là
où ils étaient en dépendance vis-àis de
d'acteurs privés qui les laissait
finalement en en en bas des priorités et
donc avec des des navires qui qui qui
restaient indisponibl pendant pendant
trop longtemps donc là il y a des choses
qui qui ont changé en en une ou deux
années de temps et et et qui devrait qui
devrait justement la mettre à à
à en meilleure situation de
disponibilité au-delà de ça je pense
qu'il est important de comprendre que ce
pilier européen l'Allemagne se voit
incarné
euh au sein au sein de l'OTAN il il est
centré sur des systèmes de commandement
davantage que sur des systèmes de combat
alors c'est un débat et qui existe
également en France à partir de quand
vous pouvez légitimement assumer le
commandement et le contrôle de grandes
unités si vous n'êtes pas un
contributeur
majoritaire déterminant de de de de
cette unité du fait de votre situation
capacitaire qui peut qui peut être
dégradé et dans quelle mesure vous
pouvez accepter d'avoir finalement de
plus petits pays qui constituent le gros
des troupes à force de de de de les
agglomérer je pense que c'est un des
défis auquels sera confronté l'Allemagne
auquel ser confrontter tous les grands
pays le Royaume-Uni a fait d'une
certaine manière aussi ce choix-là dans
le casadre de de de de leur leur revue
de de défense intégré euh mais mais mais
mais à ce stade l'accent allemand est
mis on va dire sur un certain nombre de
de
capacités de niveau de niveau haut de
grandes unités de niveau de commandement
qui qui qui explique aussi finalement le
retard accumulé sur les petits
équipements sur la maintenance et
dernier point le
zonderferman donc le le le fond
exceptionnel de dotation est un fond
d'acquisition entièrement dédié à
acquisition de nouveau matériels et non
pas lié à la maintenance et ça ça va
dans dans dans un sens préoccupant
puisque
évidemment vous achetez des matériels on
sait effectivement que les nouveaux
matériels demandent un niveau de
maintenance élevé pour pour pour leur
leur mise en service et leur intégration
au sein des forces et donc il y a
forcément des coûts de maintenance à
prendre en compte qui aujourd'hui sont
mal intégré dans le budget de défense
régulier et ça c'est évidemment un un un
un point de attention sinon sinon
l'inquiétude euh monsieur le sénateur
pour votre question
sur le
l'initiative Sky shield européenne
bouclier du bouclier du ciel on traduit
qui a été effectivement annoncé par
l'Allemagne à la fin de l'année au mois
d'octobre 2022
euh il inclut euh alors tout d'abord
c'est intéressant d'identifier que la
question de la défense aérienne et
antimissile avait été euh fixé dans l'un
des projets du concept de nation 4 des
2014 comme comme un comme un segment sur
laquelle l'Allemagne entendait pouvoir
emmener une coalition de pays européens
donc c'est arrivé euh vu de France comme
une surprise
euh mais si on prend finalement le un
petit peu un petit peu de recul les
choses étaient en fait déjà euh déjà
bien inscrites dans dans dans les
projets et finalement la guerre en
Ukraine a joué un effet d'accélérateur
plus que de plus que plus que de de de
déclencheur de de de cette de cette
initiative à ma connaissance le le
système d'Hô de fer en tant que tel
présent en Israël ne fait pas partie de
l'architecture vous avez un système
israélien qui est Aro 3 qui est un
système d' d'intercepteur antibalistique
dans la couche cche haute qui est
effectivement produit par par une
société israélienne qui est intégrée
dans issi mais pas d'homme de fer qui
couvre la
couche la couche basse la couche basse
serait aujourd'hui couverte par un
système allemand qui est
iristé produit par par par par la firme
dil et vous avez vous auriez une couche
intermédiaire qui serait la
revalorisation du système patriote
américain donc ce cette initiative
europeéan Sky shield effectivement a
posé beaucoup de questions notamment du
fait de la présence dans la couche haute
de ce système israélien à 3 qui pose euh
plusieurs problèmes ça pose un problème
technique
d'intégration d'un système israélien
dans une architecture d'alerte avancée
utanienne euh ce qui n'a pas été le cas
jusqu'à présent ce qui pose des
questions évidemment de sécurité des
données euh et euh et et et et
d'intégration technique on l'a vu avec
d'autres choix d'autres acteurs
hutaniens comme les Turcs quand quand il
voilà était décidé de de de procéder à
l'achat du du S400 non non pas que je
compare évidemment les deux mais mais en
tout cas d'acheter des systèmes et
extérieurs à l'OTAN pose pose des soucis
à la fois de sécurité de la donnée de et
et d'intégration technique euh il y a un
enjeu stratégique que la France a
notamment relevé qui est que euh la
défense antimissile balistique de l'OTAN
est quelque chose qui a été très
finement pensé sur laquelle la France
avait une position pour le moins
réservée au début des années 2000 de
manière à ne pas altérer la stabilité
stratégique euh notamment avec la Russie
ce qui fait que le le système de défense
antimissile balistique de l'OTAN tel
qu'il existe aujourd'hui est
explicitement orienté euh vers des
menaces euh autour du Sud notamment
parler de la la la la menace balistique
iranienne de manière à ne pas altérer et
à ne pas entrer dans une course aux
armements euh avec avec la Russie
entre-temps évidemment la Russie s'est
retirée de la plupart euh des régimes de
contrôle des armements mais en tout cas
euh le le le message envoyé de dire que
des pays européens euh entrent
aujourd'hui avec une l'acquisition de
système euh antimissile balistique
euh potentiellement orienté vers l'Est
est une interrogation et une une source
de euh voilà on va dire de de désaccord
aujourd'hui entre entre Français et et
et allemand et enfin vous avez un
dernier problème qui est un problème
industriel qui est effectivement le
choix de deux des trois euh des trois
fournisseurs pour le pour ce système
multicouche que serait issi qui sont
extérieurs à l'Europe alors qu'il existe
euh des des des acteurs européens
impliqués dans la défense aérienne et
antimissile notamment le consortium
franco-italien eurosam euh qui qui
évidemment interroge sur le choix
européen euh de l'Allemagne euh
l'Allemagne le justifie au titre de la
priorité de de l'urgence euh sachant que
voilà il n'existe pas de système
aujourd'hui disponible sur le marché sur
étagère du côté du côté européen euh
évidemment euh on on on la la question
de l'urgence et et et ce ce ce ce ce
débat euh aujourd'hui et euh mais mais
mais la question de ce choix de ce choix
industriel industriel non
européen de l'Allemagne et donc des de
la coalition qui qui qui est associé
pose pose question la France a organisé
au mois de juin dernier à l'occasion du
Salon du bourg une conférence sur la
défense sur la défense aérienne et
antimissile en Europe qui se voulait on
va dire une une forme de réponse euh à à
à issi avec des annonces qui ont qui ont
été faites nombre de pays euh qui
aujourd'hui s'associe s'associe à la
France qui les empêche pas d'être
également présents dans issi avec des
éléments de réponse qui sont encore
aujourd'hui à construire en tout cas
c'est un chantier à mon avis important
pour la France que d'être capable non
pas simplement de critiquer issi mais
d'apporter une réponse euh une réponse
constructive au légitime préoccupation
de sécurité des pays qui aujourd'hui
sont sont sont impliqués dans dans dans
ce projet merci je sais pas j'espère que
ça répond à la
question merci beaucoup Giselle Jourda
et Didier
Marie monsieur le Président bon monieur
donc j'ai lu attentivement votre rapport
et je voudrais vous faire préciser donc
certaines choses que vous évoquez au
niveau de la relation donc de l'OTAN de
la perception qu'on les Allemands de la
position donc française de cette entre
deux vous qualifiez cette position donc
d'entre deux et sur le point
d'articulation
avec notre positionnement vis-à-vis de
l'Europe et de l'Union européenne parce
que lorsqu'on voit ce qui s'est passé
notamment et ce qui se passe en Ukraine
où on voit que les menaces peuvent être
directe sur le sol donc européen certes
il peut y avoir cette articulation
utanienne mais il y a aussi une vision
qu'on peut avoir d'une stratégie de
défense européenne et je j'aimerais que
vous évoquiez donc le rapport donc à la
PSDC vous dites dans votre rapport
qu'elle est perçue comme un défaut donc
par les Allemands euh c'est ce que vous
que vous écrivez et ensuite je
souhaiterais savoir à à quelle hauteur
contribue donc l'Allemagne dans le Fond
Européen de défense qui court donc de
2021 à 2027 qui a été donc abondé voilà
voilà pour les pour les questions
ou oui je vois que
facile ils ont
enfin Marie merci président euh d'abord
vous remercier pour la qualité de votre
exposé qui ouvre sur beaucoup de
questions euh vous avez tout à l'heure
évoqué la
relation de l'Europe avec les États-Unis
euh nous savons
que sous l'administration Trump
euh il y a eu un un un déplacement de
l'intérêt de cette administration sur le
plan stratégique euh
[Musique]
que Trump a émis un certain nombre de de
menaces
désinvestissement de de l'OTAN en
faisant pression bien évidemment sur les
pays européens pour qu'ils atteignent
collectivement les les les 2 % du PIB en
matière de défense euh en 2024 il y aura
des élections aujourd'hui on voit que la
stratégie de l'Allemagne est alignée sur
la stratégie de l'administration Biden
selon vous quen sera-t-il si en 2024 il
y a un changement politique aux
États-Unis et dans ces conditions est-ce
que la stratégie allemande sera pérenne
ou est-ce qu'elle peut au regard de ce
qui a déjà été décidé être infléchie
vers une stratégie plus intégratrice
européenne et et j'ai une deuxième
question liée à cela quel est au sein de
la coalition allemande au pouvoir
aujourd'hui les positions de chacun à
l'égard de cette stratégie militaire
nouvelle merci pour ces deux trois
questions en fait qui qui sont
effectivement
pas simple sur sur la relation à la PSDC
je pense que il est clair que vu
d'Allemagne donc l'Union européenne est
un acteur légitime sur les questions de
défense et notamment sur la construction
de coalition
capacitaire en Europe avec une
contribution allemande au Fond Européen
défense dont je n'ai pas les chiffres
sous sous les yeux je vous pris de
m'excuser madame la sénatrice de voilà
de de ce défaut mais mais mais qui qui
qui qui est en principe proportionnel
voilà au au aux contributions allemandes
euh au budget européen en général un des
bénéficiir allement au Fed et et et à la
CSP ou pesco donc qui sont les les les
les deux grands projets de coopération
euh capacité reporté par par par l'Union
européenne euh donc une des des
bénéfices allemands qui sont sont qui
sont réeles qui sont d'ailleurs
supérieurs à ceux que la France parvient
en tirer du fait de cette capacité
allemande à intégrer des des partenaires
européens et à
rassembler finalement une clientèle et
des coalitions sur sur sur un certain
nombre de projet mais effectivement
qu'il s'agisse de du du du FD ou de
pesco c'est c'est ces projets ne sont
portés que dans la mesure où ils sont
cohérents complémentaires
et jamais concurrent avec un cadre
otanien qui reste et demeure et
demeurera pour l'Allemagne le cadre
principal de la défense du continent et
et notamment de la défense collective et
ça de ce point de vue làà on peut pas le
leur reprocher dans la mesure où il est
écrit y compris dans dans dans le le
traité de l'Union européenne que l'OTAN
demeure le cadre principal de la défense
collective et et finalement que l'Union
européenne sur le plan opérationnel
comme sur le plan capacitaire euh vient
euh finalement euh chercher euh une une
action euh en complémentaire dans les
dans les trous laissé par par par par ce
qui est le temp et ça reste euh c'est
pas forcément la la perception en France
mais ça reste la perception très
largement dominante euh en Allemagne
avec un ministère de la Défense euh
allemand qui reste fondamentalement
socialisé à l'école de aant bien avant
l'école de de de de l'Union européenne
vous le voyez dans les parcours de
carrière vous voyez dans les réflexes
qui qui qui qui qui existe et et de ce
point de vue-là l'Europe n'est pas enfin
l'Union européenne n'est pas voà n'est
pas repoussée mais elle est
effectivement considérée comme un outil
complémentaire à l'outil principal pour
les questions de défense je parle pas
évidemment de d'autres enjeux
d'intégration économique ou autres mais
que sur sur les questions de défense
l'OTAN reste le le le le le premier
cadre euh monsieur le sénateur pour
votre question sur sur les les
États-Unis et et et la question des
élections je pense qu' il faut
distinguer deux choses d'une part le
consensus bipartisan j'insiste sur
bipartisan qu'il existe aujourd'hui aux
États-Unis sur ce déplacement deintérêt
comme vous l'appelez euh cette balance
bascule vers l'espace Indo-Pacifique qui
est aujourd'hui considéré
comme comme l'axe d'effort principal
pour la stratégie nationale de sécurité
américaine c'était le cas je pense qu'il
faut jamais l'oublier sous Barak Obama
des 2010 avec le pivot vers l'Asie ça a
été poursuivi avec le style qu'on lui
connaît sous l'administration du
président Trump c'est'est poursuivi
aujourd'hui de manière effectivement
beaucoup plus
beaucoup moins brutal et
transactionnel sous l'administration
Biden et ça de ce point de vue-là
l'Allemagne a entend entend ce message
qui est envoyé de manière continue et
encore une fois relativement
consensuelle du côté américain que
américains dans le commandement om
commandement américain pour l'Europe
c'est aujourd'hui plus que ce qu'il y a
sur le commandement indopacom n'est pas
quelque chose de durable et de
soutenable du point de vue de la
stratégie américaine donc l'implication
américaine en Europe va réduire
euh et les Européens et les Américains
attendent des européens et notamment des
Allemands de faire plus et et et ça
c'est quelque chose qui est entendu en
Allemagne et Titan vender la dynamique
de titan vender de de de
recapitalisation et ces enjeux de
piliers européens de l'Alliance sont
d'une certaine manière la réponse
allemande à ce message message qui
encore une fois existait dès 2014 nous
avons entendu ce message et nous allons
faire plus avec un pilier européen de
l'alliance qui sera plus important euh
d'une certaine manière plus autonome
mais sans pour autant une avoir une
disparition totale des des des
Américains ou un retrait total des
américains avec des axes qui sont
considérés aujourd'hui par les allemands
comme irremplaçables des contributions
américaines qui sont considérées comme
irremplaçable dont évidemment euh la
dissuasion élargie offerte par par par
par les États-Unis l'Allemagne y compris
dans la coalition actuelle à validé le
le le principe de d'accord de partage
nucléaire euh avec avec la la la bombe à
gravité B61 qui demeurera euh on va dire
présente sous sous le sur sur le
territoire allemand et et et actionnable
par par la louaffer euh c'est ce sont
des aspects essentiels sur le sur le
renseignement sur les axes spatiaux
cyber et cetera les Américains sont
considérés comme durablement engagés et
et et et l'Allemagne s'attend à à un
maintien durable mais pour le reste
l'Allemagne est prête à je pense prendre
en tout cas se préparer à prendre
davantage de responsabilités c'est c'est
le sens de ce de de de ce qu'on voit ici
mais sans disparition totale euh ou sans
retrait brutal des États-Unis et ça la
question que vous posez sur l'élection
2024 évidemment euh elle est elle est
essentielle puisque euh finalement euh
si si le mouvement général est anticipé
la vitesse de ce mouvement et
l'ampleur de ce mouvement américain
pourrait pourrait venir désorganiser
déstabiliser voir provoquer une forme de
crise effectivement si ça prend les
formes que euh le président Trump avait
évoqué en 2020 avec avec un retrait
quasi total des forces américaines en
Allemagne aujourd'hui l'Allemagne n'y
est pas on va dire prête évidemment ne
ne le souhaite pas et ça ça ça pourrait
effectivement provoquer une crise de
confiance euh dans entre entre ces entre
entre ces deux alliés qui sont nos deux
alliés évidemment je
euh c'est c'est c'est toujours important
de de le rappeler au sein de la
coalition euh
allemande euh actuelle les positions
sont
effectivement différentes avec avec un
parti social-démocrate SPD euh qui
historiquement était le le le plus
euh le plus nuancé on va dire dans son
dans son héritage atlantiste et et le
plus ouvert sur d'autres sur d'autres
types de partenariats y compris y
compris européens euh le SPD a évolué
était évid évidment pris sur le sur le
choc de la guerre en Ukraine le plus
parce que c'est c'est le parti qui était
le plus compréhensif vis-à-vis de la
Russie jusqu'à jusqu'à
présent le le Parti Vert a aussi
beaucoup évolué dans sa dans dans sa
relation à l'OTAN et et et au soutien au
soutien
américain et et aujourd'hui on va dire
il y a quand même une forme d'unanimité
dans voilà le l'importance accord à la
relation avec l'administration Biden
notamment et en tout cas avec la posture
américaine telle qu'elle existe
aujourd'hui je tu veux
compléteroup et pour terminer Olivier
cadiic merci monieur pour votre
intervention vous avez rappelé
opportunément la différence de vision
stratégique de défense entre la France
et l'Allemagne l'Allemagne a fait le
choix stratégique de s'arrimer au gaz
russes pour son énergie de s'arrimer à à
la Chine pour son industrie et de
s'arrimer aux États-Unis pour la défense
nous n'avons partagé aucune de ces
orientations et je laisse chacun juge
ici de la pertinence des choix
stratégiques outrerain une crise dans le
détroit de Taïwan serait très grave pour
nos intérêts économiques et toute la
chaîne de valeur en décembre 2022 rodium
Group a estimé à 2500 milliards de
dollars le coût économique d'un simple
blocus de Taïwan les conséquences
économiques seraient plus lourdes pour
les pays européens que Cell de
l'invasion de l'Ukraine par la Russie ma
question comment la stratégie allemande
d'une armée tournée vers la défense
continentale répondrait aux aux enjeux
de
l'Indo-Pacifique merci Olivier je vous
laisse répondre je vous remercie pour
votre question qui qui rejoint aussi en
partie celle de de la sénatrice con
Mouré là-dessus sur sur sur sur la
dimension de la la la la dépendance
économique vis-à-vis vis-à-vis de la
Chine effectivement la question de il y
a une double question et une question de
réaction politique politico-économique
allemande à cette hypothèse d'une crise
dans le détroit Taiwan la capacité par
exemple de l'Allemagne à mettre en place
des sanctions un paquet de
sanctions contre la Chine
similaire à ce qui a été fait contre
contre la Russie et effectivement le
coût économique pour l'économie
allemande et pour l'économie européenne
d'une manière générale parce qu'il faut
pas se le se lurit ici l'Allemagne et et
est finalement peut-être la plus avancée
mais mais demeure assez représentative
de la situation européenne serait
incommensurablement supérieur euh et et
d'ailleurs l'impact sur l'économie
globale et les chaînes de valeurs serait
serait incommensurablement supérieur et
c'est pour ça que à mon sens en tant
qu'Européen nous devons nous y préparer
dès maintenant et réfléchir à la fois
sur la sur sur sur sur les les les
modalités euh et euh et la la
faisabilité de T sanctions ne serait-ce
que dans une logique de on va dire non
pas de de dissuasion puisque en France
c'est pas forcément le terme qui sera
utilisé mais en tout cas de euh de vis
de de viser à décourager la Chine pour
pour crédibiliser cette cette menace de
sanction nous devons y réfléchir à mon
avis ensemble dès dès maintenant sur la
contribution militaire euh allemande sur
l'Indo-Pacifique en général et sur la
crise de de Taiwan en particulier euh
les messages ont été assez clairs
notamment du côté de la marine allemande
que cette contribution serait minimale
euh aujourd'hui la bundesver dans son
ensemble euh entend avoir une présence
euh euh dans l'Indo-Pacifique à raison
de un déplacement euh par an un
déploiement par an dans l'Indo-Pacifique
de manière rotative euh sur les trois
principales forces armées donc vous
devriez avoir une un déploiement naval
en 2024 dans le cadre de l'exercice
rimpack
24 avec avec une frégate et et un et un
et un ravitailleur et un bateau
ravitailleur vous vous avez eu la un
déploiement aérien l'année der cette
année un déploiement terrestre l'année
précédente il y avait une une une
frégate il y a euh 3 ans euh 3 ans et
demi euh donc donc ça reste ça reste on
va dire de l'ordre de la
euh de la présence symbolique
aujourd'hui euh les préoccupations y
compris françaises pour une présence
coordonné européennes en Indo-Pacifique
sont sont entendues elles sont
aujourd'hui considérées
comme voilà moins moins prioritaire que
que l'enjeu européen de ce qui est de la
marine allemande notamment c'était très
clair que leur horizon aujourd'hui
s'était reconcentré sur la mer Baltique
et dans une moindre mesure l'Atlantique
Nord le l'océan Indien l'océan Pacifique
à forcerie sont considérés quand même
comme bien loin aujourd'hui de leur zone
de déploiement naturel d'action où ils
espéraient en tout cas avoir un un effet
militaire le le le l'effet de ses
déploiements en ind Pacifique est
aujourd'hui quand même essentiellement
symbolique et
politique
merci beaucoup je crois qu'on a terminé
avec les questions de mes
collègues merci pour vos sujets
particulièrement éclairant c'est vrai
que les questions de coopération
industrielle en matière de défense sont
des sujets qui nous intéressent
fortement ici vous savez qu'on a
beaucoup travaillé sur les questions du
mgcs et du SCAF que je pense grâce à
l'initiative du président Cambon il y a
2 ans maintenant le SCAF a quand même
quelque peu été relancé avec ici des
réunions qui ont permis de rencontrer
d'abord Éric TRAPIER et
puis Dirk Hale lorsqu'il était encore à
la direction de des affaires chezbus
c'est quelle branche defense and space
et donc on est très attaché évidemment à
essayer de faire avancer ces sujets
parce que on est je pense un certain
nombre à penser que d'un point de vue
industrielle la coopération avec
l'Allemagne au niveau européen est une
nécessité mais pas que il faut aussi
montrer aussi qu'on est capable de
coopérer avec d'autres pays européens
voir d'anciens pays membres de l'Union
européenne comme la Grande-Bretagne sur
des sujets de coopération industriel
parce que compte tenu des montants et
compte tenu des investissements majeurs
qu'il y a qu'il est nécessaire de mettre
en place évidemment ces coopérations
sont importantes mais le rapport tel que
celui que vous venez de N présenter
montre aussi les différ les divergences
de de point de vue et d'analyse qu'il y
a entre la France et l'Allemagne quand
la France considè que l'Allemagne est un
et la France forment un couple et que
les Allemands considèrent que nous
formons un partenariat parmi d'autres et
que évidemment nous ne sommes plus et
vous l'avez dit le principal j'allais
dire partenaire de de l'Allemagne en
Europe donc tout ça est évidemment un
travail très intéressant qui va nous
permettre également de partir à Berlin
puisque nous avons une délégation de la
Commission de des Affaires étrangères et
de la défense du Sénat et de la
Commission de la Défense de l'Assemblée
nationale accompagnée du chef
d'état-major de l'armée de terre qui se
rendra à Berlin le 6 décembre 6 novembre
pardon pour évoquer ses points de de
coopération euh euh moi je je veux avoir
confiance on a eu avec
quelques-uns une réunion récente de
l'Assemblée parlementaire de l'OTAN à
Berlin à copenhag pardon il y a une
dizaine de jours dans laquelle j'ai on a
organisé une bilatérale avec les
Allemands qui m'a fortement impressionné
parce que on était deux Français ils se
sont ils sont arrivés à 11 allemands et
tout un staff et on a compris que la
donne avait un peu changé voilà et donc
nous verrons de quelle manière nous n
nous nos nos discussions et nos débats
auront lieu à Berlin mais en fait il
faut il faut voilà je crois qu'il faut
qu'on persévère et qu' on se rende
compte aussi de nos de nos faiblesses
j'entendait Hélène tout à l'heure parler
du du Lecler je rappelle quand même que
sur la le rétrofit ou en tout cas
l'entretien du Lecler on avait pas par
exemple anticiper suffisamment la
rénovation des turbomachines qui vont
coûter quelques centaines de millions
d'euros et cetera et cetera donc il faut
qu'on soit aussi nous plus réactif et
plus mais je pense que voilà la loi de
programmation militaire actuelle va le
permettre en tout cas on a donné les
moyens normalement d'être plus réactif
en matière de MCO et de d'entretien du
matériel mais il est bien évident qu'un
certain nombre de problèmes se posent à
nous mais merci beaucoup pour cette pour
ce rapport d'abord parce qu'il est très
important pour les travaux à venir pour
mieux comprendre l'Allemagne et mieux
comprendre peut-être la relation que
nous devons avoir avec eux et il nous
sera d'une forte grande utilité pour les
travaux à venir merci beaucoup pour
votre habituel Fran parler et puis
j'espère qu'on aura l'occasion
rapidement de vous de vous retrouver
mais je pense que vous serez peut-être
auditionné sur le rapport budgétaire je
sais pas en tout cas pour invitation
monsieur le Président
meroup rappelle à mes collègues qu'on a
une réunion de bureau qui va suivre dans
quelques
minutes